a lei do fust no hu o 3 2 num voo
oriundo só que tem que negar o fato de
pessoal e quem fala andar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais um melhor do que
o mostrado de que mais um vídeo com
brinquedos que ninguém só que eu fique
muitos muitos brinquedos novos chamam
suas forças
[Música]
falo aqui muitos brinquedos deste estudo
que são colecionáveis que vaiem dentro
de ceni 3 portanto tem aquela coisa
nojenta por membro e acho que vai ser
muito longo a lei só admita e thabita
acima você vê uma coisa e ville walo
hoje vai ser muito nojento e ao mesmo
tempo divertido porque nós vamos
encontrar aqui uma escritura dentro das
nossas famílias e estão mais de 150
colecionado então eu tenho que muitos
brinquedos acho que eu vou continuar
tudo e todos disse não temer que também
é nossa é só pra mim não conheço muita
71 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
eu vou sortear alguns destes brinquedos
para vocês portanto fiquem atentos lá no
instagram é porque você tirar tudo lá
então fiquem diante desse de vocês podem
ganhar brinca de destino integrado vai
estar aqui em baixo na descrição pessoal
passei lá fica entende a foto do seu
tédio e eu acho que por a mãe disse
vocês podem levar um autógrafo de um
tenente que o brinquedo e eu posso
participar pode manter o posto de galã o
ator eu sei que ele vai tomar não é só
fazer um anúncio de grande participar e
agora vamos lá abrir então os nossos
esforços à ea outra coisa ou outra coisa
que tinha uma excelente e gigantesca
festa
olha só é muito grande só mesmo só que
ela faz
[Aplausos]
op é e eu imagino que taurino em muitos
brinquedos além de juro zero hora sobre
pessoal dos nossos fãs as forças e para
fazer um gesto mas precisamos de água e
estava aqui eu já tinha o nosso
pouquinho com água como olha só é porque
estão brinquedos especiais ainda não
sabe como é que isto 0 pelo flamengo né
mas gestão sanitária local rcn ainda
funciona sempre com água já jogou comigo
que deságua então o que nós vamos fazer
nós vamos oferecer em campo uma por uma
e temos que colocar a água dentro dela
para os monstros e irem lá dentro eu
acho que isso muitos nem são mais 150
nou em risco os esforços depois force
one da folha não faz força e um
brinquedo as forças ou euros todos os
processos nada não conhece disse exigir
mais pobre eo chato daqui pro lado vamos
pensar porque é que isto vem com duas
tenistas que vem já com 2 suas fotos com
uma formiga e uma dentadura né e muito
estranho e podem ser estes todos são
muitos cristo porque só pra mim mas o
atlético é só pra mim para as pessoas
que participarem no sul da ilha uma
sanita duas tenistas a cair 11 levantar
o tampo do tocoismo 2 colocar água e
puxar editar e abrir a tampa e ver o que
tem lá dentro vai aqui também o papel
contudo esforços podem ser aqui dentro
olha só isso muito bem que os insetos
têm os mais sujos temos clean pão e tem
uns que a dispensa em uma espécie de
pílula
mesmo assim o christus sus 15 fuzis
nunca se falou sobre migrantes que são
tipos tais mil tem muita coisa que serve
o prende são muitos dias
só comentei acho que vou ter os 150 ela
gastou mais do que 50 que diz mais de
150 km 158 e 52 não saímos devem ser
muitos cometem se acham que eu vou
conseguir os todos com instrumentos de
brinquedo falar e muito bonito próprio
então vamos lá não tem dia que você
niterói só colocar a água
olha aí nós amiguinhas agora é só abrir
o autoclismo
assim cobrir este também agora é só
colocar água na água porque não foi xuxa
só ri melhor
é melhor fechar um dia antes que saiam
justus não em tablado coroou a natura
lei que será tema de um filtro muito
curioso
ok vamos lá meter água nesta rock agora
é só pra acreditar
o uol ou para que a equipe se mantém
dois pontos de interrogação beijou o que
vai acontecer quando eu agitar a avenida
otto 321 vai o leitor é parceiro do uol
por seu tom e monstros 21 23 21 vai que
isto é não sei acho que é composta por
lá o próximo item pelo time que tem pelo
olha aí ô ô ô não tem textura meu e
rápido comenta ela
amarelo pessoal vejam só dentro de um
tamanho tomaremos veja o que cada
candidato e eu muito estranha textura eu
acho que é tão rápido não sei ok vamos
lá ver onde é correto está ok o rato é
um dos melhores que já conseguimos um
muito usado primeira para lá liga
próximo a cnte eu acho que vai ter aqui
um prêmio muito bom porque só ele e é um
inseto acho que é incerto mas querendo
olha só uma música e outra em setúbal
gostei muito de 7 neste aqui dentro
dessa caixinha também vinham estes a
formiga
minha mãe fez um emotivo nita cake é
formiga das ligadas à e o que é isto
olha só uma gelatina é que não sei acho
que é errado colocar essas latina a não
estou mas não tinha uns e bonita é o
benfica ou seja estão que os viciados em
limpeza que isso não é só um monstro
sujo né isso é um dos 17 que é formiga
pois fato muito temos muita coisa pra
gabriel foi muito coisa onde vêm e
outros e que o mistério eo amor de deus
vamos lá ver como é que o gol é muito
grande é muito grande a não sou do skal
não sei é uma lagosta entrega de mais de
um parceiro olha aí passa quando os
cabeças só esta embalagem vejo a
quantidade de foice forças que se olha
aí muitos vejam só pessoal sem 12345678
fosse for só numa embalagem é muito para
abrir a embalagem sol e vamos agora
abrir s n ta muito grande um olha é isso
é muito grande nos dias 1º está aqui
dentro eu que tenho que fazer acha que o
temporal que também gostam e não sei
acho que não pelo menos não agora
acho que é sobre pela violenta e 32 mil
o u1 olha só o que tem aqui dentro
a lei tem muitos sacos pretos e que
fossati mistério um tempo que parece
frio também deu susto muito grande
coração
acho que são especiais não saiu pois
abre o nosso primeiro vai ser lá um
carro no bumbum é um caminho que tenha
um dos mais fortes é um dos rostos mais
forte no próximo à igreja por sinal o
negócio
acho que sim para que sejam gregas azul
e outro mal é por ela já tem dia que 31
de maio próximo
tan tan tan tan e não é muito difícil é
um golfinho com um claro assim pães
salva vidas e afinada e piratuba colocou
a equipe na turnê
acho que insiram 14 dos monstros bons
guaramirim a próxima ceni é época que já
abriga grande através vamos lá
defendendo outra logo os trouxe um
arquivo de agosto rápidos amigo pois
posso ter algum não sabe porque sempre
meu ok só vamos lançar aqui um desafio
eu vou escolher aqui o que possa ser
irmão kaká vai escolher outro que passe
e o que ir pra ganhar por othon eu vou
escolher aqui eu vou tentar esclarecer
muito raro muito raro wall street flick
e vou tentar com o espírito fui eu quero
este cachorro como enquanto fora as
parceiras que os copos olho pode ser
este aqui este rocheta ela foi então
hotel é um país que eu não gosto eo meu
cachorro com a língua falada bom eu acho
que esse peixe e arroz pode ser aqui eu
acho que sim
ae outro do fim outro tiro lá não ser um
beijo não pode ser igual
não pode tenho acho que isso vai levar
ao salão então olha que eu posso falar o
amor pois o hotel para isso falam falam
mas o que o pessoal roxo na nené não só
continuar suas fotos que nós temos além
disso muitos não temos muita coisa pra
abrir para lá com a escola embalagem que
agora pode ser esta festa que estamos a
abrir esta esta que vem com uma cena não
é esforço mistério e um aqui existe
muito pouco nenhum pouso muito bonito é
muito bonito expulso mas nobre
ele tem um desafio já o mistério eu acho
que isso aqui é um dos que gosta do
empate acho que sim e há nenhum cliente
ficou muito além e rolando por aí eu tô
ali pra cá temos aqui nosso cuba neto
no entanto olha comer um pãozinho take e
outro e eu acho que alguém ganhou o
desafio é ruim ninguém garantiu
olha aí o i temos visto de fora temos
aqui mais um inseto e eu acho que não é
só as que têm os insetos todos porque
assim o carácter é ter e nené
olha só já por ser um um livro meio de
outra mulher então automaticamente nós
já não ganhou
vamos lá abrir o que é muito bonito
toque muito o o outono crido é um povo
no jogo incrível é isso aqui não é um
pouco uma lua né
é preciso não sei e ela está suja tem
uma coisa meio na casa
é ela vai definir que ficou suja é uma
cereja
eitá poderá ser eleita podre e meu
cérebro é muito bonito muito bem feito
olha só a igreja toda lágrima eu te
pegar nenhuma destas caixas o futebol
não viu não faltou só acho que vou fazer
uma coisa muito divertido agora eu vou
já abrir algumas tenistas vou colocar
água luz e evitar tudo ao mesmo tempo e
brito ao mesmo tempo só isso que fossem
cnt já sei o que eu acho que não vou
saber se é assim
já em munique cinco tenentes vão encher
tudo ao mesmo tempo uma do duas três
quatro cinco cães foi mais um gol falou
do cinema mas não preocupam até porque
não estou a pensar avançar porque não
tem água de ceni eo vício no mês 0
era pra dizer que o brinquedo
agora vamos tampar e sunitas agora é só
aguardar o interesse mas consegui fazer
os agentes vão digitar tudo levaram
todos para lá vem a cair nesta primeira
semita é um gato com duas cabeças muito
louca querendo filmes 11 publicou o
livro e fish e maureen esse pior caso
nem muito mais motivo os dias logo pela
manhã mas não aqui dentro do espaço de
cair próximo cine fieo acho que nós
nunca achou tudo isso não acho
ganhei eu ganhei eu estava bem lá no
fundo está tudo é inerte duelistas um
tiro eu passei dois meses mas só comigo
olha o que eu queria fazer só meu muito
outro não cachorros com línguas e este é
o meu favorito quebrou um tabu nunca
ficam dentro ganhámos pessoal ganhou de
que o desafio mas vamos tentar encontrar
numa altura em que ainda é um país falam
rosso para a próxima saída que inventa
que tenho muito ver oo uma serpente com
duas crianças que tudo montante é tudo
com duas crianças que se vê lo campeão é
um texto foi lido olha lá e se um
estranho e muito phishing próximas e
militar eo que isso tem gente que parece
o governo a base que me fez ter um
estreito fricção os force de rua nós
temos um cachorro e isso eu acho que
aquela tampa da cgt sabe pela rua i am é
um monstro que segundo artur pizarro
disse que a família ainda falamos mas
vamos abrir a porta eu acho que falta
uma selic de 5 calma um mais um inseto
mais um feto
olha aí o pouco que temos mais um lado
um falei olha só que é uma súmula não
sei que estamos tendo tomado com molho
um comunicado que está muito brilho
explorar a imagem pessoal para lá agora
também muitas vou deixar aqui embaixo da
abrin embora lab estúdio mesmo nem aí
meu desejo eu vou treinar muita água
calma sem tipo de início dar incentivo
disse o calma tudo que pode agora vou
embora agora será que vai funcionar eu
já sei se ainda à tarde ela estava o
outro
bora lá pessoal agora só te para as
nossas centrais e editar tudo ao mesmo
tempo ver o filho de ter estudo
o hu hospital saltou lá dentro de um
carro quando ele confiar é isso que
agora vamos abrir esta lei e também no
fundo
mas minha senha dos quadros do fc porto
foram agora abre pessoal e por um e ver
o que tem dentro e comentem o que vocês
acham fácil e vai servir cento mas se
lula quem vai ser eu ainda estou em
busca do país falou o show how to
acho que vai ser o principal rosto
humano pretende a ai meu não é a emc
situei é um povo dentro de um charro
roll como ela entrou dentro eu não saiu
está muito bem mas tem que mais 171 e
7,1 e em aveiro que tem mais um mais um
monstro roxo outra cobra e sequer tem
aquilo que gosta seu agente o torcedor
que estou a fazer aqui o maluco é que
esteve frente não existem surge da dor e
da via na hora nenhum gol méxico era
para ser um sinal de tocar e eu acho que
é um viciado mil empresas estão vendo
coisas desse gênero que fabrica os
colecionáveis
eu acho que é muito bom contra o formiga
só que este vírus outro pólo ou é igual
à outra coisa coreana aí muito difícil
ou o que o oeste foi a que isso é muito
verde na mão como é que somente estão no
abrigo não conseguia abrir esta maluco é
cap agora eu acho que vou te falar
comigo imagine aí foi aqui espeto pede 3
2 1
o dólar está muito verde
[Música]
eu acho que esta questão são figuras
especiais é um saco do pão com um outro
alento de que dentro que tem e é um
destino com pelo ouro e chutou que toca
toca toca
ei fim mas estou bem estou em um
banquinho está quieto mais rápidos nem
estava no futebol há muito verde no link
eu vou deixar esse lado porque isso é
muito próximas e nem tem olha aí tem
muita coisa vir por aí já temos e este
novo kim stupple muito estranho não só
tem um braço a fio olha eu só tenho um
braço próximas à direita
este item que está tirando mais um pouso
e mais uma cereja agora que vão começar
a ser muito importante porque nós já
temos muito mais forte muito muito mesmo
então é normal que começa a existir ou
externo festa muito grande
o técnico está tirando aqui olha eu lhe
fiz este é muito louco é um caracol como
atendente bem grande mas é um erro e um
provável que nós já temos só que roda de
tereré ou seja um olho que temos aqui
mais dentro é um passeio que também já
temos dois caminhos um é bom só no final
vou juntar todos os esforços que eu
tenho o meu e vai dar com as duas mãos
cheias só o que aconteceu e tentar
evoluir sem editar assim ainda tem o
papel lhe damos a 31
o gosto eo gosto rua eu acho que as duas
são os que eu gosto mais é o caixote do
lixo sarjeta os marroquinos e tenho aqui
que não sei ainda tenho aqui que não sei
que o edifício estava bem no fundo eu já
fui contra o que temos aqui também são
januário próximo dia 6 de abril é muito
ciumento brasil temos muitos brinquedos
muitos brincantes fofos e passam a noite
inteira ela temos outro com pelo i a eu
estou mas contra corpo com filmes mas
ceni 3 mais um cãozinho
aí tem mais duas vezes também assumiria
toda suja aí que quem aqui eu acho que é
outro que obtido outro sopro treinou
hoje mas deixa claro é porque faltam
mais três tenistas de 18500 muito pobre
o mas nem sei se terei mais um inseto
2007 na mesma fita como é que vai ser
que esses números me sobre tio é tanto
jurídico o atleta tem um tubarão a 5ª
série e há muito era altura calma tá
difícil buscar o tubarão é muito difícil
lidar de modo calma calma é uma mulher
que se fez homem que tocava uma música
que lembra das coisas ou as diferenças
mil de luvas cresce sempre todos duas
vezes é porque não temos 80 semita tudo
que vem de ceni tem duas cabeças porque
mais aqui dentro um ponto em sete anos
já tem uns dois destes dois médicos e
uma derrota na última semana entre os 18
que nós tínhamos e agora vamos lá enfiar
o dedo aqui imagina se eu fizer simples
vinho que tem aqui dentro um louco é um
inseto mas voou ontem dois insetos
eu acho que nós temos urgência atitudes
têm muito bonito aí estão sempre da
noite só veja só com tirado suas forças
que nós temos aqui olha isso muitos
muitos e eu ainda tenho aqui muitos
problemas já não vão abrir neste vídeo
você não vai ficar gigante porque são
muitos mas já sabendo somente dos
brinquedos que estão aqui eu vou
conseguir oferecer então passaram esse
grupo que vou fazer lá mais uma foto
participa em que pode ser que vocês
ganharem de vocês podem é e só espero
que vocês tenham gostado da cnt sensus
cnt fará palestra nesta classe num raro
eu estou há cinco anos com um tubarão
branco nós já temos mas com o tricolor
todos têm trabalhado aqui todos não
gostam declarou dentro mas deus como -
dentro do cnt na europa e já temos esse
aqui também mas aí só espero que vocês
tenham gostado aqui dos flashes fours
olha aí
já sabendo só participava num extremo
espero que vocês tenham gostado fiquem
bem até a próxima hora
[Música]